do you think this Christmas is going to
be considered better than last Christmas
yeah the question on everyone's lips the
PM keeping his fingers crossed with a
new coveted variant and the potential
for tougher restrictions the big unknown
but even turning on the Christmas lights
didn't quite go to plan for Boris
Johnson
now accusations that last year when
things looked very different for the
rest of the country were the lockdown
looming staff here in number 10 held a
large party seemingly breaking covered
rules adding to a run of negative
stories for the Prime Minister a
narrative the opposition a keen to
capitalize on as millions of people were
locked down last year was A Christmas
party thrown in Downing Street for
dozens of people on December the 18th
what I can tell they're a right
honorable gentleman is that is that all
guidance was followed completely the
defense seems to be no rules were broken
well I've got the rules that were in
place at the time prime minister of this
party they're very they're very clear Mr
Speaker you you must you must not have a
work Christmas lunch or party he's not
denied it
he says he says no rules were broken
he's taking the British public for Falls
back in late December last year the
country was heading into another
lockdown and many of us were facing
Christmas without our families there
were strict rules on who you could see
no parties no mixing outside your
household and there were some business
exemptions but I've been told that in
Downing Street there were a number of
parties where staff gathered enjoyed
drinks and chatted late Into the Night
number 10 says no covered rules were
broken
but how can both things be true
with Boris Johnson's reputation already
taking a hit in the polls how will this
go down with the public when so many of
us canceled our Christmas and
we find out that the person who told us
to do that didn't it just feels like a
real kick in the teeth maybe you know
they were overworked they were having a
hard time but so was everyone in this
country I was working in covert ICU
I didn't get to have a Christmas party
this year the prime minister is urging
us all to go out and celebrate
very very modded thank you very much but
if allegations of rule breaking cut
through the hangover could be painful
Kate McCann Sky News
and Kate joins us live now so how big a
problem is this then for Boris Johnson
Kade
well I think in the first instance it's
problematic because of course as the
Prime Minister gets asked repeatedly
about whether it's one rule for him and
one rule for everybody else it
underlines that political attack line
that Labor's Kia stama is so determined
to pursue that the Prime Minister isn't
following his own rules and it becomes
even more important when you think about
the fact that in just a couple of weeks
time we are likely to know more about
the new variant of covid-19 and that
could go either way it could be good
news welcome news or it could be
damaging news for the country and that
might mean further lockdowns Boris
Johnson is residing over a party that
already is frustrated with him they are
worried about the way he's managing his
party they are concerned about the fact
that he goes to lockdown measures to
more restrictions when they don't
believe that he should if he's going to
ask them to implement more of those
later on in December this argument that
during a time when some of us couldn't
see our families when we were heading
into a lockdown when things were dire
for restaurants bars pubs lots of people
around the country if it's found out
that he actually ignored those rules and
allowed his staff to then making the
argument to reintroduce them at a time
when his party already doesn't want to
do that will become really really
difficult indeed for the Prime Minister
and for the labor party this is the gift
that keeps on giving they would like to
keep this idea alive that Boris Johnson
says one thing to everybody and does the
complete opposite of course Downing
Street say no rules were broken but this
story isn't going to go away easily